Okay everybody. We are gonna talk about the final exam.
This is basically building on everything you've learned in this class.
It's just another cohesive project, and what I'm going to ask you to do is build a wiki.
For those of you who don't know what a wiki is, I will give you a demo.
It should look something like this. Here's the front page of a wiki.
A wiki is just a website where any page can be edited.
For example, if I were to click edit on this page,
you see the HTML of this page and I can add some text.
Let's add a blank line. So I just added some text in this text box and I click save.
Then we save the page and then it has this text in here.
Now, one of the things that's cool about a wiki or at least in this one that we want you to build is
you can go to any URL or in this case /newpage, which doesn't exist yet.
If the URL does not exist, it'll redirect you to another URL.
In my case, I'm using /_edit and then the page name where you can edit some content in here.
And if you were to click save, it will take you to that URL.
In my case /newpage with the content and of course you can edit this content.
Let's add a link to the front page.
We just use the anchor tag with an href to slash, which is the front page.
And if we click save, we can see that it renders that HTML I typed as a link.
If I were to click on this link, it'll take me to the front page, which is a slash.
W'll go through the specific requirements in the instructor comments, but the important thing--
the first thing--is if you type in a URL that doesn't exist, you go to an edit page.
If you type in a URL that does exist, it renders the content of that page,
and you can edit the content of that page if you want.
Now, I've been logged in this whole time. You should have user accounts integrated in this.
If I were to click logout here, it keeps me on the same page.
What this did is that it did just like we did in Unit 4.
It cleared my user clear key and just redirected me to the page that I came from.
I can view any page logged out, I can view the front page as well,
but I can't edit any pages. See, the edit link is gone.
Now, we can't grade how things look very well, so we're not going to bother doing that,
but we will try to submit an edit form while being logged out and that should fail.
Now, I will log back in. Now notice it's the same signup form we've been using all along.
Actually, in the version I'll put online, I'll probably clean this up a little bit before I do that,
because it's been bugging me in the code, but this is actually
the exact same code I've been using the whole time.
I'll log in as my user and you can see now I have a new edit link.
That's the gist of the main wiki--of course, instead of clicking login,
I could also click signup to create a new user.
This is the same form we've been using for this entire class with the errors and whatnot.
If I were to try to create a user that already exists, I give out that error.
That's why I'm going to sign a different user spez2, click submit, and I'm logged on as spez2.
That is the main task that I'm going to ask you to do. Log in. Log out. You've already done that.
Editing a page. It's basically a simple form submission and some fancy redirecting in there.
Again, in the instructor comments we'll include more specifically how to do that.
When you have that working, submit the URL here.